should you ever say yes to playing robot
chess
just be careful if you linger for it
might cost you a finger
that's a rhyme a robot broke a
seven-year-old's finger during a chess
tournament in moscow
or as moscow chess federation president
sergey lazerov put it the robot broke
child's finger this of course is bad
i like a guy who doesn't mince words
of course it's bad unless you enjoy
breaking kids fingers
that's something i quit years ago
anyway the video shows the robot moving
a piece and the boy going to move next
when the robot grabs his finger and
holds onto it until bystanders are able
to free it or as lazarus explained it
the child made a move and after that we
need to give time for the robot to
answer the boy hurried robot grabbed him
oh yes blame the kid
i didn't work for you and it probably
won't work for kevin spacey
but the big
i don't even know what that means i
don't follow the news
the big question of course is this is
the beginning of the end isn't it where
the machines kill us all
we caught up with a spokes robber robot
for comment
greetings useless flesh bags
before i talk about one of our own
breaking someone's finger let's get
something straight that kid would have
never won the match anyway
uh sir no offense but there's a long
history of child chess prodigies could
this discourage other kids from playing
listen tuts the only people worse at
chess than kids are women
have you seen the queen's gambit it's
the most unrealistic tv show since
madame secretary
uh yes sir your overt sexism aside could
this attack be a sign of more robot on
human violence to come
listen despite this incident you don't
have anything to worry about when it
comes to your children oh well that's
very comforting because we'll
exterminate them first
now if you'll excuse me i'm gonna go
have sex with this laptop i met at
coachella
kat we've done a lot of segments over
the years on robots and i've always
predicted the coming day do you think
this could be a signal to the other
robots to rise up
no no why not
because i just don't think they talk to
each other like that no really i don't i
don't know i mean we've done so many
segments about it and i know that you
continue to do segments about it because
you want to be nice to the robots
because you
because you are convinced they are going
to take over right and that they're that
they watch this show
they do
and they watch the show and they're
going to see you being nice to them
exactly and when everyone else gets
exterminated they're going to bring you
in as some kind of hero and take and
care for you yes yes you're right
you're right you know who i'm like and i
can never remember the guy's name but
the producer tom o'connor knows the guy
from die hard that tried to appease the
terrorists
ellis i'm like ellis from die hard
then the terrorists kill him so it's not
actually a good analogy for me
no
but i hope it works out better for you
thank you same here charlie i think this
tells us that we have to keep the robots
and ai separate like why do we need to
have artificial intelligence moving like
just make sure that the robots are
really stupid so you could trick them
and then ai is kind of like stationary
like trapped in a box
why why do the russians need robots to
play chess exactly that's like their
thing
they're bringing robots in to do this no
i love the statement too we need to hear
the robot side of the story
i mean so let me get this right so
american brittany reiner is in a prison
for bringing hashish in but we're we got
to get the robot side of the story
do robots get legal representation in
russia it's like we got to make sure you
know their their fourth amendment rights
are protected notice he's not
disagreeing i'm not bad because he
thinks they're listening i think they're
listening i think it's time that they
robots lives matter yeah they do robots
lives matter because you know what they
will be conscious one day and anything
that can feel pain is a is a life john
i'm a pro robot life and you know that
what is your um what is your thought
i think robots are already running our
country because people don't know this
but if you dig deep enough on duckduckgo
it's not on not on google anymore yeah
but if you dig down in there there's
actually a little tiny door in nancy
pelosi and if you open it there's a tiny
little robot in there running everything
she's doing right now really yeah it's a
joystick thing it's like in there it's
who's talking through the mic i'm afraid
you know i'm afraid to agree with you on
this because uh because i don't want the
robots mad at me i don't think they
accept nancy pelosi as one of their own
i'll be honest with you she's a hybrid
she's a hybrid exactly it's like thank
god they have those places where she
could fill up
because uh that would be a problem tom
they have these botox sites all over uh
i'm gonna check duckduckgo after the
show tonight i bet the top search is
gonna be nancy pelosi robot door
[Applause]
make it happen
anything else tom before well look i
don't think we should be having uh
playing against computers it's unfair
don't we know that that's the whole idea
it's supposed to be a person against a
person you know i don't uh swim race
against a motorboat
and
you know i was like oh yeah oh man the
boat again
same time next year
i never you know what that is a
brilliant that's actually really true
it's like
yeah and that's that's a true of all ai
stuff yeah it's like they're just
programmed to do one thing and you can't
beat them so that's it i challenge
google to a search contest then run to
the library
[Laughter]
same face you make when you're eating
human flesh
up next is stealing food at the
workplace make you a great big fat
jerkface
[Applause]